cruzando los dedos hacia arrancaron
estas enfermeras hacia un hospital de
cuidados paliativos cerca a manchester
para atender un llamado de urgencia con
el pánico es pánico porque en mi mente
estoy pensando en ese paciente cuando lo
vi la última vez estoy pensando en la
pobre familia que está desesperada que
nos llama por teléfono y espera una
respuesta rápida
una decisión riesgosa ante la falta de
combustible a la que se enfrenta reino
unido- causada por una insuficiencia de
conductores cisterna para los
trabajadores de cuidados paliativos
responder a tiempo es esencial los
pacientes piden asistencia cuando los
dolores se tornan insoportables y el
personal de salud acude para aliviar los
sin embargo ante el desabastecimiento de
gasolina se han enfrentado a la dualidad
de ir en búsqueda de combustible o de
atender las urgencias de sus pacientes
arriesgándose a no llegar a whitman y si
logramos pasar las estaciones de
servicio que tienen filas así que
sabemos que hay combustible pero no
hemos podido hacer la pila porque el
tiempo es crítico para nosotros fresco
los foros ante la urgencia este hospicio
decidió pedir combustible por las redes
sociales y algunos respondieron al
llamado y en facebook anoche que estaban
pidiendo combustible para los
automóviles asistenciales para ir a las
casas y para darle cosas a esas personas
sabía que yo no tenía algo de
combustible así que se los ofrece
incertidumbre reina en varios sectores y
ni siquiera el anuncio del primer
ministro británico boris johnson de que
el ejército asumiría el despacho de
combustible brinda tranquilidad entre
los más vulnerables